Kevon psorbos time in the spotlight is
diminished since his Hercules days but
if you think you've seen him around
lately
you might just be right keep watching to
see what he's been up to
in 2012 Sorbo published a book
containing some shocking revelations in
the later seasons of Hercules
The Legendary Journeys which aired from
1994 to 1999 viewers started to notice a
shift away from the title character and
onto the shoulders of other stars no one
knew why there was a sudden flood of
guest stars and it wasn't until Sorbo
published his book that fans learned the
truth in 1997 he suffered three strokes
as the result of an aneurysm true
strength
mike journey from hercules to mere
mortal how nearly dying saved my life is
the story of just what happened to Sorbo
he was in the middle of a promotional
tour for call the Conqueror when he
started to feel some odd sensations in
his left hand and arm but doctors
brushed it off the pain worsened during
a workout and he went to his
chiropractor after driving home he
started suffering all the symptoms of a
stroke it was then that doctors
discovered and removed the aneurysm that
was blocking blood flow to his arm after
returning to the Hercules said Sorbo
endured after-effects like fatigue
depression and anxiety attacks he still
suffers from nerve damage residual pain
the occasional migraine and a 10% loss
of vision and he says that the
experience made him realize what was
truly important to him his wife and his
faith it also made him want to share his
story in the hopes of helping others
through similar experiences we are
survivors and we should never ever give
up in 2014
fantasy fans got to see Sorbo dawn his
medieval gear once again with the
release of mythic a quest for heroes his
second collaboration with a production
company era storm when he was approached
to read the script he was absolutely an
unconditionally on board even though he
was playing the wizard rather than the
warrior this time around mourn mythical
movies follow the dark spoor and the
necromancer arriving in 2015 and then
the iron crown and the God Slayer in
2016 when Sorbo spoke with geek dad in
2015 he acknowledged that while his role
as the heroines mentor was limited in
the initial
he was going to play a bigger part as
the story went on when he was asked by
Fantasy had become his go-to genre he
admitted love that world no rules in the
fantasy world writers can do what they
want and make it come to life just fun
to be a part of the fantasy Sorbo became
famous for his portrayal of a legendary
character and in 2017 news broke that
he'd soon be associated with another
famous franchise when it was first
revealed that he would be playing a
recurring character on the CW's
Supergirl he was simply described as one
of the show's many bad guys the mystery
surrounding just who he was going to
portray built for more than a month
that's practically forever in internet
time but finally the studio eventually
confirmed that he'd be stepping into the
boots of MA Nels father
blargh and Sorbo ended up appearing in
the three episode arc with former Lois
Lane Teri Hatcher playing his wife in an
interview with Entertainment Tonight he
revealed that if things had gone a
little differently back in 1993 he would
have ended up playing Superman opposite
Hatcher and Lois and Clark the new
Adventures of Superman
but alas that part ultimately went to
Dean Cain instead Sorbo is a devout
Christian and recent years have seen him
frequently turning his attention to
faith-based films in 2014's God's not
dead he stars as an atheist professor
who challenges his students views on the
existence of God God is dead
in 2014 he was also in revelation Road
the black rider a tale about what's left
after the rapture and let the lion roar
which he played reformation leader John
Calvin he even played Joseph in 2016's
Joseph and Mary a retelling of one of
the Bible's most well known stories in a
2016 interview with gospel Herald he
spoke about why he thought bringing
faith-based films to the big screen was
important I think that most people would
agree that faith-based movies back in
the 70s 80s and even the 90s were very
cheesy poorly written and poorly acted a
lot of people were turned off by them
because they were also too preachy we
live in a world where people don't want
to be told what to believe in and what
not to believe in you have to walk a
fine line to hold an audience Sorbo
shows no signs of slowing down
even teaming up with Fox News Sean
Hannity for let there be light which is
about an atheist who has a near-death
experience since 1997 Sorbo has been
involved with almost every
aspect of a charity called a world fit
for kids as a celebrity spokesperson he
spoken out about things like the
nationwide dropout rate for schools and
childhood obesity pushing to get a world
fit for kids to go outside of California
and into other parts of the country at
its heart the charity is an after-school
program that touches on everything from
physical fitness to training teens to
become better mentors for younger
children - preparing kids for what
they're going to be confronted with when
they reach the working world all kids
deserve that kind of encouragement but
the reality is most don't get it that's
why I'm involved the world fit for kids
Sorbo is headed up fundraisers and
participated in public service
announcements about issues like
providing workplace mentors to students
interested in pursuing their dreams
in 2005 he took on another charity role
as a spokesperson for the after-school
Alliance an organization dedicated to
providing safe and educational programs
for students so even if you haven't seen
much of psorbos recent film and TV
appearances he's still been working
steadily in whatever capacity he's
passionate about check out one of her
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]